happy Star Wars Friday everybody we got
to talk all about Emperor Palpatine
secret contingency plan should he die we
actually got some brand new information
[Music]
welcome and Sky's board has been
expecting
I'm looking forward to completing your
entire you will call me last there's a
brand new novel called empires and that
informs all of this backstory and what's
going on during the last Jedi and may
have offered some clues about the
origins of supreme leader snoke being
beyond our own galaxy so if you're new
to the channel I do Star Wars videos
every week be sure to subscribe to get
everything
I'm even doing a special giveaway that
I'll explain at the end of the video if
you haven't been reading the books since
Disney bought Star Wars a couple of
years ago since force awakens came out
there are about four books that take
place between the events of Return of
the Jedi and the force awakens that
inform what's going on answer a whole
bunch of big questions about character
motivations backstory and this new
secret Palpatine contingency plan most
of the time we spent with Emperor
Palpatine is actually during the
prequels we learn a little bit about
what he's thinking inside his head
during the original trilogy he's really
just commanding the fleet trying to turn
Luke Skywalker there's very little about
his machinations that you actually learn
about he is the tragedy of Darth
Plagueis the light no I felt on the
story the Jedi would tell you it's a
syst legend Darth Plagueis the Dark Lord
of the Sith so powerful and so wise he
could use the Force to influence the
midi-chlorians to create life he had
such a knowledge of the dark side he
could even keep the ones he cared about
from dying it's really only in the
aftermath book series that you learn
about his obsession with what's going on
beyond the galaxy he's still very
obsessed with the dark side of the force
so what he does is he hoards artifacts
in installations all over the galaxy
trying to map the Unknown Regions
because he believes the order
of the force or somewhere beyond the
balance of our galaxy in the Unknown
Regions is one of the most dangerous
places to try and go that's why it's
called the Unknown Regions because it's
been so hard to map it refer to it
affectionately is a labyrinth of solar
storms rogue magneto spheres black
hole's gravity wells and things far
stranger so I know you're like wait a
minute what does that mean far stranger
what's going on in the outer rim the
Emperor wasn't the only one that was
obsessed with the Unknown Regions the
Jedi had long used the planet Illume
which is in the unknown region is a
source of Kyber crystals for their
lightsabers so they would send
younglings out on the crucible ship
during Clone Wars to go look for them
the force make physical a Jedi is comes
great responsibility with that yes
protect others how does a Jedi hmm if
your own lightsaber you shall but first
harvest your critical each one of you
must many tears I am in ownership
teaching many a Jedi before you and I
will continue teaching many a Jedi
aren't you cause what you want but
inside my memory banks I contain a
record of every lightsaber ever made and
the Jedi who fashioned which you choose
simple grip
the curved approach one inlaid was abode
of the continuity well Thanksgiving or
Blackhawk if you didn't tell that was
actually David Tennant that played that
droid he was actually a big character on
Clone Wars
that's all still canon so Emperor
Palpatine knows about this but he feels
like there's even more to be learned and
gained from going beyond our galaxy in
finding another galaxy that's free from
all the crap that's been happening with
the Jedi free from all the turmoil so he
wants a fresh start with the remnants of
his empire so one of his many
contingency plans should he die is that
he has a plan in place were the remnants
of the Empire to go start anew somewhere
else with trusted advisors in a new
strong foundation on the dark side of
the force
but like all empires not everybody
agrees about this so you have this
really curious area of space that's
really dangerous and hard to traverse so
the emperor just continued
to send expeditions out to try and find
things find a way through it
so that they can go to another galaxy
but eventually they discover some
ancient computational mechanisms that
allow them to safely traverse through so
the Emperor sets his plan in motion
should he die the Battle of Endor I know
it sounds crazy that the Emperor someone
that powerful in the dark side of the
force would actually believe that he was
capable of death with all that prequel
talk about Darth Plagueis being able to
survive death so that gets into the
Wills obviously people learn how to make
forced ghosts the living force becomes a
really big thing but our books like dark
Empire where he actually does have
secret clones hidden in the deep core on
bits where he becomes a clone of himself
it was a really cool story but that's
all part of Star Wars legends so
technically it's not canon so you can't
really take it into account so all of
this unknown regions first-order origins
going beyond the galaxy stuff is still
canon because it appears in the new
books the epic part 1 of this plan is to
lures the remnants of the rebellion
fleet to the planet jakku where the
empire has this secret base called the
observatory it's one of Palpatine secret
installations where he's been hoarding
things so Palpatine chooses a successor
galius racks is a big person in the
aftermath series he's the leader of the
Imperial fleet but he also has another
chosen successor who's a Darkseid force
cultists called tashu remember should he
die he wants the new empire that will
form in his wake to be founded on the
dark side of the force so they're going
to lure the rest of the rebellion to the
planet jakku and detonate a very special
bomb that will blow up the planet in the
rest of the rebels fleet with it the
problem is is that another Imperial
officer named race low that they
introduced during rebels she's been in
the comic book series who's been
following galius Rex's orders doing all
this dirty work for him
sees that he plans to detonate this bomb
on jakku and he'll kill a bunch of
Imperials with it it just thinks that
he's going to be the worst person ever
to lead the new empire that's going to
form so she kills him in what ends up
happening is as the rebels defeat the
Imperial fleet the super stardestroyer
that they're on crashes to the planet
and that's what you saw in that very
first Star Wars The Force awakens
trailers that Ray is scavenging parts
from sort of like a tomb for the
remnants of the Empire
[Music]
at least to say the bomb never goes off
so the planet jakku never blows up
because Ray's there at the beginning of
force awakens but what happens is is
this new race lone character become
Supreme Leader effectively and takes
them with their special new star charts
that they've discovered into the unknown
regions where they begin to form the
first order what happens next is is that
the Imperials build their strength in
the first order slowly starts to form in
the Unknown Regions beyond our galaxy
Supreme Leader Snoke only arrives when
they come back in full force
he didn't come from our galaxy so what
happened is is that there's this mystery
missing period of time when Rey's Sloane
took the remnants of the fleet beyond
our galaxy that we don't know about yet
snow comes back with them there's all
this political back channeling black
market dealings where they begin to fund
the creation of the Starkiller base and
that leads us to the beginning of force
awakens the really interesting thing
about this is that Star Wars hasn't
dealt too much with things happening
outside the galaxy itself the use of
wrong was a race of beings that Luke
Skywalker's disciples fought in the
legends books to nail legends books it's
not canon anymore but there are a lot of
creatures that live beyond our galaxy so
it makes sense that other galaxies are
just as bio diverse as our own galaxy in
star wars so that's not the race that
Snoke comes from but it just helps
support the claim that Emperor Palpatine
was correct when he assumed that the
nature of the force came from something
beyond our own galaxy it's not just all
completely localized to our galaxy
that'd be a very egocentric view of the
force well let me know in the comments
what do you think about the idea of
Snoke being someone from beyond our own
galaxy it would certainly explain how he
was not around during the events of the
original trilogy during the prequels but
he is also force sensitive so there's a
whole bunch more backstory they reveal
in this empires end book so I recommend
that you check it out but I'll continue
to do bonus videos about it you just
learn all kinds of really awesome things
about the characters between Return of
the Jedi in the modern film so it's
going to be a lot of fun to take through
it so I'll continue that on my Star
Friday next week but because the road 1
DVD is coming out that's what the
giveaway is going to be for now so all
you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber leave a comment on this video
I'll announce the winner the next time I
post a Star Wars video so what's going
to happen later today is there's some
really cool injustice footage the drop
that I'll do a trailer video for if
there's some cool of Deadpool news about
him spinning off the x-force movies so
we're trying to get to that as fast as
possible thank you so much for watching
everybody let's high five while you wait
for that to post you can click here to
learn about Leia's backstory with
supreme leader snoke and you can click
here to learn all about what's going on
with a brand new Nightwing movie this
coming May
[Music]